ah
[Music]
these no no banana great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
two weeks in Europe is gonna be great
I'm just gonna enjoy my trip I got with
MJ feel like really pretty and therefore
I have value no no that's not what I
meant
I'm messing with you that's really nice
someone nice to finally meet you
spider-man your Nick Fury put some
clothes on let's go for a ride
unique theory just hijacked our summer
vacation
awesome
get gifts Parker but we have a job to do
are you going to step up or not
we're all alone
and friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one
he's no spider-man what is it with you
and spider-man but he looks out for the
neighbor it has a dope suit and I really
respect him sub blues are so good hey I
am late happy nice thank you you too
thank you new dress yes it is hot you
know what just happened
[Music]
[ __ ] passport Peter Parker here to pick
up a passport please
any toothpaste let's pack your suit I
just want to go on my trip with my
friends Europe doesn't really need it
friendly neighborhood spy
[Music]
you look really pretty therefore I have
value no it's not messing with you you
look pretty too sometimes II want you to
do my first unloved I just finished my
coffee so nice to finally meet you
spider-man
your Nick Fury put some clothes on let's
go for a ride is she gonna be okay like
that might want to turn him over so he
doesn't swallow his tongue
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
awesome
get gifts Parker job to do
are you going to step up or not
your friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's no spider-man
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighbor it has a
dope suit and I really respect him
sup dickwad
[Music]